[Musik]
mit
med
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally
trails heute gibt eine stütze bieten und
horte die ihr zum beispiel einfach mal
sonntags zubereiten von mama und papa
oder auch mal für einen kindergeburtstag
jetzt hier eine torte mit einem
buttermilch boden einer zitronencreme
aprikosen stücken und hier oben drauf
ist noch eine aprikose orangen steht und
libyen die zuckersüßen die hab ich auch
aprikosen hälften mit ein bisschen weg
gemacht und die karte geht wirklich
super einfach vor allem die bienen den
größten für mich bist und bleibst hinter
werden die torte lieben ich zeigen hier
zuerst einmal wie man den teig erstellt
und zeigt euch dafür die zutaten für den
teig frau sechs eier 300 gramm zucker
eine prise salz und etwas weil exakt
jeweils 300 milliliter buttermilch und
sonnenblumenöl habe ich 400 gramm mehl
und backpulver 50 gramm mandeln wer mich
bereits fein gemahlen und eine
unbehandelte betonen so erst einmal
nämlich jetzt die eier und verlosung mit
zucker salz und vanille extrakt in etwa
vier bis fünf minuten zu einer cremigen
masse
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich bei niedriger stufe noch
die zwei flüssigkeiten dazu und zum
schluss freilich jetzt macht die
zitronenschale ab und holte dann mit
mehl backpulver und den gemahlenen
mandeln unter
[Musik]
später zeigt jetzt ein gefüllt in meiner
vorbereitung war gering
den habe ich bereits auf 26 cm
eingestellt hier unten ist übrigens
völlig normal dass ein minimaler ram
sind steht wer einfach austritt und zwar
deswegen weil einfach der flüssig ist
falls ihr einen flüssigeren 3 cups könnt
ihr auf jedem weg bringen einfach mit
wasser vier einschlagen jetzt kommt
derzeit in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
160 grad ober unterhitze für etwas jetzt
mit 70 minuten erreicht wird gebacken
und ich habe ihn auch komplett
abgelassen und jetzt kann ich mich um
die füllung für man bestellung wird eine
patronen quark sahne creme mit absurden
stücks und ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten für die füllung traurig drein
unbehandelter zitronen ein päckchen agar
agar etwas wasser flagstone es kaum
schlagbar sind hier das susanna partsch
etwas vanille extrakt 80 gramm
puderzucker 500 gramm magerquark 100
gramm schoko plättchen und hier habe ich
noch aprikosen aus droht wir müssen
zuerst mal die zitronen die habe ich
bereits gewaschen und da werde ich jetzt
die schale auf dem fein abreiben
da der zitrone was mit dazu und zwar
brauchen zumindest nicht 100 milliliter
und den rest für mich dann mit wasser
aus zwei milliliter flüssigkeit
[Musik]
wasser mit rein und dass ankara
und dann darf die mischung ist aufkochen
unterlassen drei minuten kochen und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
sahne schlagen dafür gebe ich hier in
serie schufen und bis jetzt kurz an und
das mit 6 telefon seiner partei schlagen
die bahn habe ich jetzt bereits kühl
gestellt die zum steif geschlagen
das alter gibt es für ihn eine ganz
lehre schützen damit einfach ein
bisschen schneller abkühlt oder lass ich
selbst etwa lauwarm abkühlen bevor ich
es in quark verbindet und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
ein paar aprikosen fein hacken
da lege ich jetzt ein paar für die
degression weg damit sie entscheiden
entweder sechs oder 36 eingelöst
[Musik]
das akw schönlau war und ich hab hier
eine stele gemacht die macht ist
eigentlich fast immer und zwar gebe es
dann einen teelöffel oder misserfolg in
ein kleines schildchen stellt in den
kühlschrank und acker wird bereits bei
38 grad etwa fest das heißt hier sehe
ich schon das ist sogar noch warm aber
ist eben schon fest und ak kann ich
immer ganz gerne weil es einfach die
pflanzliche variante zu statine ist und
auf die verarbeitung viel viel einfacher
da man ackerweg nicht aufkommen muss und
zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen und
gelatine ist es genau andersrum die darf
man auf keinen fall auf kochen da gibt's
auch einen kleinen vorteil wenngleich
erst einmal quark mit dazu sind zwar
erst einmal ein löffel damit der quad
einfach jetzt nicht locker
schön einrühren und dann kommt der rest
mit dazu mit fotos zucker und vanille
extrakt war mal eine veranstaltung und
da hab ich dann mit dem kopf und
gebacken und hab dann graf meine ländern
mehr angst gemacht auf meinem was hoch
und hab da in graz ag aufgekauft und der
chef von dort von der veranstaltung da
wollte unbedingt ein foto machen hinter
der küche praktisch als forderte und hab
dann einfach ausprobieren und hat dann
das gerade auch gekochte aka aka
probiert und meinte becker und wir uns
alle vor lachen nicht mehr gekriegt weil
neue aka aka schmeckt hat noch nichts
nach wasser und deshalb nicht flüssig
aber ich wollte es dann im ersten moment
ein bisschen eklig aber naja
leider muss immer gerne zurück
puderzucker mit rein aber da kann ich
beim hoch an gott sei dank sagen es gibt
mir immer das erste feedback
er sagte immer wenn es schmeckt und auch
mal nicht schmeckt auch wenn es weh tut
das stimmt
mein größter kritiker morath sie machte
sie zum schönen dickflüssig da gebe ich
noch das restliche sonderpaket sein dass
auch kurz 1 und da kann ich auch schon
die sahne unterheben
mit märz auf einem rühren schon wie die
macher jetzt immer verwirrt jetzt muss
ich schnell arbeiten stellt das mal kurz
zur seite und nehmen den abgekühlten
tortenboden und schneiden es zweimal
waagerecht durch
[Musik]
um den tortenboden herum kommt jetzt der
tat ring
deswegen finde ich auch super praktisch
wenn ich sie zum wachsen und bitte auch
die tropfen befüllen nehmen kann
jetzt kann ich hier in die creme noch
die streusel einbringt dann habe ich
eine leckere stracciatella creme dann
nimmt jetzt so viel wie er möchte
doch nicht die ganze stadt unter genau
wo die aprikosen
[Musik]
es gebe etwa 106 m auf dem ersten
tortenboden und streicht die klinik und
fülle die torte auf diese weise
[Musik]
die torte schön glatt und ich denke sie
ab und zwar mache ich immer gerne mit
einem zweiten retter dort jetzt kommt in
den kühlschrank gestellt denn jetzt
möchte ich noch dicker so oben drauf
machen und das wird natürlich die schöne
fruchtige glas orangensaft von aprikose
zeigt nicht mal die zutaten für die
glasur frau und 150 milliliter
orangensaft 100 gramm aprikosen den
granada und wer möchte kann auch 20
gramm schokolade zu finden das ganze
geht ist auch ganz schnell das heißt ich
muss erstmal den orangensaft
da kommen die aprikosen mit raimund
werden schön fein püriert
jetzt kommt das führe in einen topf
gemeinsam mit dem acker und kommt jetzt
auf ganz kurz aufgekocht und dann zwei
minuten lang gekocht werden und gut für
mich jetzt um gefüllt so könnte einfach
ein bisschen schneller ab vancouver die
speicher richtig gut die wärme und das
ganze stelle ich jetzt hier auch so ein
akku packs damit schneller abkühlt und
gäbe es hier auch schon mal die
schokolade mit rein sind die stars darin
schmelzen offizier lauwarm abkühlen
aber ich muss zu kontrollieren damit es
nicht so schnell fest wird jetzt nehme
ich schon mal die torte die bereits etwa
15 minuten im kühlschrank und es kann
hier den rand den hessischen betrieben
verschmiert kann hier zum saubermachen
und war den lehrern im teig steht hier
am radfahren entlang und kann das kann
ich ganz vorsichtig den gurt hierüber
verteilen
die torte ab und stellen sich beim
ersten vier stunden den linken schreibt
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal um die abfuhr kümmern und daraus die
bienen zaubern
damit geht die aprikosen helfen die habe
ich ein bisschen trocken getupft und
braucht jetzt einfach nur noch ein paar
sachen um die bienen ist raus zu
modellieren und fahrerische dekorateure
rapid amateure bereits geschmolzen und
einfach einen gefrierbeutel gegeben im
spritzbeutel geht auch dann habe ich
hier ein bisschen schokoladen fondant
bereits weiß geknetet suche augen habe
ich hier und ein paar mandelblättchen
mit werde ich zuerst einmal mit dem
schoko von ganz einfach die köpfe formen
selbst denkst einfach mal dran passt von
der größe her und wie zucker augen die
klebe ich dann mit etwas essbarem kleber
dran
[Musik]
habe ich jetzt eine ganz dünne spitze
weg geschnitten und zwar mit macht
lustig streifen
[Musik]
die menschen werden ist einfach
eingesteckt und dann mache ich einfach
mit dem messer ein kleines
[Musik]
im kopf können jetzt entweder nur dran
setzen
so mache ich das jetzt oder ihr können
zum beispiel an spaghetti nehmen und es
damit befestigen oder auch einen
zahnstocher aber dann müsst ihr
natürlich diejenigen die die torte essen
auch informieren dass da eben was drin
steckt doch nur vor herausnehmen
[Musik]
die zweite ist dass er zuerst krise
jetzt mal auf eine sportklasse
[Musik]
am rand las ich zuerst naked dann sieht
man einfach diese schönen geschichten
und jetzt werde ich nur noch die
bienchen drauf und ich bin auch am
überlegen das entscheide ich spontan
ob ich noch blumen oder zum beispiel
schmetterlinge drauf
[Musik]
und benito und zwar besprechen und
wahnsinnig machen anschneiden und
probieren würde ich hier nochmal die
flöten zeigen und zwar bis diese blauen
und weißen blüten genommen und im innern
sind wir eigentlich weiß und blau
also haben keinen stempel ihnen in dem
noch nicht einfach mit dem lebensmittel
fließen angemahnt und das beatles größe
farbe befördert so kann man einfach
selbst bestimmen welche farbe dieser
stempel haben oder zb erzählt die torte
an
[Musik]
das ist ein ziemlich großes stück aber
ich hab mich übers herz gebracht die
pläne zu verschneiden und zwölf bühnen
haben mich ganz darauf gefasst
deshalb wurde er doch mal was
ludger und die torte schmeckt auch
wirklich sehr gut ich habe es vorhin
links von uns ein bisschen von dahinten
gedacht und in den boden ab macht und
die creme ist wirklich super lecker
pedro nicht gerade mit diesem flecken
schokoladenstückchen und mit der
frischen aprikose ist es wirklich sehr
sehr lecker also auf jeden fall
empfehlenswert und elisabeth auch noch
machen wollt geht auf meinem blog
news.de dass dieses gesetz noch mal ganz
genau ich wünsche euch jetzt mal ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal
[Musik]
also ich bin perfekt auf grund der höhe
der torte dass man sie in 16
kuchenstücke ein teil
das heißt man macht kuchenstücke achte
große und dann ist das eine billion und
blümchen torte
denn dann freuen sie sich zu zweit
einfach teile entweder durchschreiten
oder zusammen essen und egal